>>> WHAT IF SUPPOSED VOTER
SUPPRESSION DOESN'T ACTUALLY
SUPPRESS ANY VOTES?
I'M MICHAEL SMERCONISH IN
PHILADELPHIA.
HERE'S WHY I'M ASKING THAT
QUESTION, YOU KNOW THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE DOOMED IN THE
MIDTERMS BECAUSE HISTORICALLY,
THE PARTY OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE MAKES GAINS IN THE
OFF-YEAR ELECTION.
COME NOVEMBER, REPUBLICANS NEED
ONLY GAIN FIVE SEATS TO TAKE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
AND SINCE THE CIVIL WAR, THE
OUTSIDE PARTY HAS WON AT LEAST
THAT NUMBER IN ALL BUT JUST FOUR
ELECTIONS.
WELL, A NEW CNN POLL SUGGESTS
THIS YEAR WON'T BE ANY
DIFFERENT, DESPITE ALL THE
DEMOCRATS' ATTEMPTS TO RALLY
THEIR BASE AROUND EMMITTY AROUND
DONALD TRUMP.
56 OF THAT GROUP SAY THERE'S
LITERALLY NOTHING THEY APPROVE
OF BIDEN HAVING DONE SO FAR.
JAMES CARVELLE ONCE FAMOUSLY
SAID IT'S THE ECONOMY, STUPID.
WELL, DISAPPROVAL FOR BIDEN'S
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY IS NOW
AT 62%.
WHEN ASKED THEIR TOP-TWO POLICY
ISSUES, REDUCING INFLATION WAS
NAMED BY 42%.
HOW'S THAT GOING?
WELL THIS WEEK CAME NUMBERS FROM
THE BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS.
CONSUMER PRIZES ROSE 7.5%, THE
MOST IN 40 YEARS, WHILE REAL
WAGES DECLINED 1.7%.
GAS PRICES STILL UP 40 FROM A
YEARS AGO WHICH EXPLAINS WHY
PRESIDENT BIDEN REACTED DURING
HIS FIRST TV INTERVIEW.
IT WAS THIS WEEK WITH LESTER
HOLT, FIRST OF THE YEAR.
>> I THINK IT WAS BACK IN JULY
YOU SAID INFLATION WAS GOING TO
BE TEMPORARY.
I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
WONDERING WHAT YOUR DEFINITION
OF "TEMPORARY" IS?
>> WELL, YOU'RE BEING A WISE GUY
WITH ME A LITTLE BIT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT'S YOUR JOB.
>> SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES ARE
AFFECTING EVERYTHING FROM FOOD
IN THE SUPERMARKET TO COMPUTER
CHIPS TO AUTO PARTS.
AND, OF COURSE, THERE'S NOW
CANADA WHERE A SO-CALLED TRUCKER
BLOCKADE WHICH STARTED AS A
VACCINE MANDATE PROTEST NOW
FURTHER THREATENS THE U.S.
SUPPLY CHAIN.
INTERNATIONALLY, THE SITUATION
IN UKRAINE SEEMS ABOUT TO BOIL
OVER WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
TELLING AMERICANS TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY, QUOTE, AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, WITH FORCES AMASSING
ON THREE SIDES OF ITS BORDER-.
SECRETARY OF STATE ANTONY
BLINKEN SAYS THE U.S. BELIEVES
THAT A U.S. INVASION WITH BOMBS
AND MISSILES WOULD BEGIN, QUOTE,
AT ANYTIME.
TODAY, 11:00 A.M. PRESIDENT
BIDEN SCHEDULED TO SPEAK WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
MEANWHILE, THE MEXICAN BORDER
REMAINS POROUS FOLLOWING A YEAR
OF RECORD ARRESTS.
IN 2021, BORDER PATROL AGENTS
MADE 1.9 MILLION ARRESTS THAT'S
A RECORD HIGH.
HOMICIDES AND VIOLENT CRIME
STILL ON THE RISE IN MANY
AMERICAN CITIES.
THURSDAY NIGHT, BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE, FIVE COPS HOT IN
PHOENIX, THANKFULLY, NONE
FATALLY.
IN DECEMBER, A CNN POLL FOUND
THAT 76% OF AMERICANS FEEL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING
ENOUGH TO ADDRESS VIOLENT CRIME.
AND THEN THERE'S COVID.
APPROVAL OF THE PRESIDENT'S
HANDLING OF THE CORONAVIRUS IS
JUST AT 45%.
WE'VE GOT THE NEVER-ENDING
CHANGES OF COVID PROTOCOLS.
MASK ON, MASK OFF.
HOW MANY SHOTS, MAKE ONE, QUOTE,
FULLY VACCINATED.
A PREVIOUS INFECTION COUNT AS
IMMUNITY.
MANDATES IMPLEMENTED THEN STRUCK
DOWN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD LESTER HOLT
HE THINKS DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
ENDING MASK MANDATES ARE MOVING
TOO QUICKLY BUT ADDED, YOU KNOW,
A TOUGH CALL.
HERE'S THE THING, TAKEN
TOGETHER, IT'S TOUGH TO SEE ANY
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
FOR DEMOCRATIC EFFORTS TO
MAINTAIN CONTROL OF THE
CONGRESS.
MAYBE WHERE SO MANY CONTRACTED
OMICRON THERE WILL SOON BE
RELIEF FROM THE PANDEMIC.
AND THAT WILL BENEFIT BIDEN.
PERHAPS A SUPREME COURT REVERSAL
OF ROE V. WADE WILL MOTIVATE
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS TO VOTE IN THE
MIDTERMS BUT EVEN IF DEMOCRATIC
FORTUNES TAKE A TURN FOR THE
BETTER THERE IS WAY THAT THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS WILL BE WAGED.
YOU HAVE MANY REPUBLICAN STATE
LEGISLATURES ORDERING STATE
VOTING LAWS IN A WAY THEY SAY IS
VALID PROTECTION BUT AREAS
ALLEGE IS VOTER SUPPRESSION.
CHANGES TO EARLY IN PERSON
VOTING.
REQUIRING VOTER I.D. AT THE
POLLS.
SENDING ABSENT T.E.A.S WITHOUT
REQUEST.
AND REQUESTS TO VOTE BY MAIL.
BUT DO STRICTER VOTING LAWS
REALLY DIMINISH TURNOUT?
ACCORDING TO MY NEXT GUEST, NOT
SO MUCH.
HE SAYS IN THE 2020 ELECTION,
THESE VOTING RULES HAD ONLY
MINOR AFFECTS ON TURN OUT AND NO
EFFECT AT ALL ON THE DEMOCRATIC
TURNOUT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
SO WHAT MIGHT THAT MEAN FOR 2022
WHEN MANY NEW LAWS HAVE ONLY
RECENTLY BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
JOINING ME, ALAN ABRAMOWITZ, HE
PERFORMED AN ANALYSIS FOR
CRYSTAL BALL UVA WHERE HE'S A
SENIOR ECONOMIST.
PROFESSOR, WHAT DID YOU DO AND
WITH WHAT RESULT?
>> WELL, WHAT I DID, ESSENTIALLY
WAS TO ANALYZE THE VARIATION IN
ELECTION LAWS THAT EXISTED IN
2020.
AND LOOK AT THE IMPACT OF THAT
HAD ON BOTH VOTER TURNOUT AND ON
THE OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION IN
THE STATES.
AND WHAT I FOUND WAS, THAT WHILE
THERE WAS WIDE VARIATION ACROSS
STATES IN THE AVAILABILITY OF
ABOSENTEE VOTING AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF STAYS OF OTHER
IN-PERSON VOTING AND OTHER
REGULATIONS, THAT, WHEN YOU
LOOKED AT THE IMPACT THAT HAD ON
TURNOUT AND ELECTION RESULTS.
BASED ON WHAT WE WOULD HAVE
EXPECTED GIVEN THE RESULTS IN
THOSE FOUR STATES FOUR YEARS
EARLIER, WHAT I FOUND WAS THAT
THERE WAS ONLY A VERY SMALL
EFFECT ON TURNOUT.
AND NO EFFECT AT ALL ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
>> IT SOUNDS SO
COUNTERINTUITIVE.
WE'VE SPENT SO MUCH TIME TALKING
ABOUT ALL OF THE CHANGES TO
VOTER LAWS.
WERE YOU SURPRISED?
>> I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED AT
THE SMALL EFFECT ON TURNOUT,
ESPECIALLY, ALTHOUGH MY RESULTS
ARE ACTUALLY CONSISTENT WITH
SOME OF THE EARLIER RESEARCH
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THINGS LIKE
EARLY IN-PERSON VOTING AND
ABSENTEE VOTING.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THOSE
PROCEDURES IS THAT THEY'RE
POPULAR.
THAT PEOPLE LIKE VOTING TO BE
CONVENIENT.
THAT PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES, IF YOU
PROVIDE EARLY VOTING.
IF YOU MAKE ABSENTEE VOTING
READILY AVAILABLE.
THAT'S CERTAINLY TRUE IN 2020
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE
ELECTION WAS TAKING PLACE DURING
A PANDEMIC.
BUT WHAT THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
AND WHAT MY RESEARCH SHOWS IS
THAT WHILE CONVENIENT AND WHILE
WIDELY USED THERE STILL SEEMS TO
BE RELATIVE IMPACT ON EITHER A
PERCENTAGE OF RELATIVE VOTERS
THAT GO TO THE POLLS OR
ULTIMATELY ON WHICH PARTY THEY
END UP VOTING FOR.
>> SO HOW COULD YOU POSSIBLY
KNOW WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD BE
FOR THE MIDTERM OR FOR THE NEXT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WHEN SO
MANY OF THE LAWS AT ISSUE HERE,
WHETHER YOU CALL THEM VOTER
SUPPRESSION, WHETHER YOU CALL
THEM BALLOT SECURITY, MANY OF
THEM HAVE ONLY BEEN PUT ON THE
BOOKS SINCE 2020?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT WE CAN LOOK BACK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2020.
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS CONSIDERABLE
VARIATION IN THE ACCESSIBILITY
OF EARLY VOTING AND ABSENTEE
VOTING IN 2020.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAD STATES THAT
STILL REQUIRED AN EXCUSE FOR
ABSENTEE VOTING.
WE HAD STATES THAT MAILED
APPLICATIONS TO VOTERS.
AND WE HAD TEN STATES THAT
ACTUALLY MAILED BALLOTS DIRECTLY
TO VOTERS.
SO WIDE VARIATION.
WIDE VARIATION IN THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE VOTE THAT WAS ACTUALLY
CAST BY ABSENTEE BALLOT.
SO, WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT VARIATION TO SEE WHAT
EFFECT DID THAT HAVE IN 2020.
AND LOOKING BACK AT 2016 AS OUR
SORT OF CONTROL FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S WHERE I FOUND THAT IT
HAD RELATIVELY LITTLE EFFECT ON
TURNOUT, AND NO EFFECT ON VOTE
OUTCOME.
AND THEN USING THAT RESULT TO
PROJECT WHAT THE EFFECT OF THESE
SAME SORTS OF VARIATIONS WOULD
BE IN 2022 AND 2024.
OF COURSE, WE CAN'T BE CERTAIN
IT WILL PLAY OUT THE SAME WAY,
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
PREDICTION THAT WE CAN MAKE,
BASED ON RESULTS THAT I FOUND
FOR THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> PROFESSOR, QUICKLY, I HAVE
BUILT MY SURVEY QUESTION OF THE
WEEK AROUND YOU AND YOUR DATA.
YOUR BOTTOM LINE IS WE SHOULD BE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE WAY
BALLOTS WILL BE COUNTED THAN
BALLOTS WILL BE CAST.
TAKE 30 SECONDS AND EXPLAIN WHY.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IS
DEFINITELY THE CASE.
I'M MUCH MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE NEW LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THAT ARE BEING PUT
IN EFFECT THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE GOVERNANCE OF ELECTIONS AND
WHO GETS TO COUNT THE BALLOTS,
ULTIMATELY.
THE FACT THAT WE SEE CHALLENGES
TO ELECTION OFFICIALS.
THE FACT THAT WE SEE CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR SECRETARY OF STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO ARE
FOLLOWING THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
IN HIS CLAIMS OF WIDESPREAD
FRAUD IN 2020, WE HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW SOME OF
THOSE OFFICIALS WOULD RESPOND IN
THE EVENT THERE'S A CLOSE
ELECTION.
AND THERE ARE QUESTIONS RAISED
IN THE FUTURE.
>> ALAN ABRAMOWITZ, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO READ WHAT
YOU PUBLISHED AT SABATO'S
CRYSTAL BALL.
TO EVERYBODY AT HOME, I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT YOU THINK.
GO TO MY WEB
WEBSITE @SMERCONISH.COM.
THIS IS MY SURVEY QUESTION.
WHICH DO YOU THINK IS A GREATER
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, THE WAY WE
CAST OUR BALLOTS OR THE WAY WE
COUNT THEM?
TWEET MY AT MY SMERCONISH PAGE.
THIS COMES FROM THE WORLD OF
TWITTER WHICH SAYS, WHY ADD FUEL
TO THE FIRE, MICHAEL?
THE WORDING IMPLIES THERE IS A
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
DON'T WE HAVE ENOUGH MISS TRUST
NOW?
CK GRAMMY WAITING FOR SPRING,
THE PRESIDENT THINKS IT'S
THREATENED BUT NOT IN A
CONVENTIONAL WAY.
TO THE POINT WHERE HERE'S
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY DID THE
ANALYSIS AND FOUND THAT PASSION
MOVES THE NEEDLE.
SURE, IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP AN
EYE ON LAWS THAT APPLY TO BALLOT
ACCESS, BUT IN THE EVENT, PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO COME OUT AND VOTE
ARE COMING OUT TO VOTE.
WHAT YOU N